It can, at points, seem horrifically clear
that simply no one really cares. They barely
notice our presence, they hardly stick around
to listen to what we have to say, they catch
none of our hints – and they are overwhelmingly
preoccupied with their own projects and day-to-day
concerns. On the basis of such evidence, it
is easy for us to fall into a large, damning
and dangerously heart-breaking conclusion
about our situation: that we are profoundly
alone – far beyond any possibility of connection
or empathy. But the truth may be at once more
mundane and rather more hopeful. Most of us
humans are extremely keen to help when we
notice an urgent need, but we are also continuously
distracted, grievously taken up with our lives
and unlikely to spot that there is anything
at all the matter with people around us unless
the problem is spelt out in the clearest,
most unambiguous terms. Then, but only then,
will we swing into action and bring the whole
of our intelligence and will to bear on another’s
pains. In other words, we respond well to
screams, but terribly to hints. The issue
comes particularly to the fore in tragic cases
where someone we know takes their own life.
We are certain that we would, if we had known
how desperate they felt, have done pretty
much anything to help. At the same time, we
also know that we didn’t enquire very much,
didn’t look too closely for hints and must
surely have given off an impression of constant
busy-ness. We feel, understandably, entirely
wretched and callous. We would be wise to
rehearse these facts about human nature without
rancour or surprise when we are next at our
most fragile and desperate. The apparent indifference
of others truly is only apparent. We need
to learn to scream. Sadly, we tend to lack
any confidence to do so precisely when it
would be most necessary, because a primal
embarrassment takes hold of us around being
in need, as if it was in the remit of any
human to get through life by their own wits
alone. Part of the tragedy of being desperate
is how illegitimate our agony feels to us.
Yet we should never allow ourselves to forget
that, whatever the surface indifference of
others, we are surrounded by people who, when
they see an emergency in front of them, will
jump into icy rivers to rescue total strangers.
If we know unambiguously that someone (even
a casual acquaintance) needs us a lot right
now, we will probably drop everything and
run to assist. But at the same time, we are
hopeless at reading minds or taking hints.
The next time we are in trouble, we must remember
not to hate ourselves for requiring help and
should call out, hopeful in the knowledge
that most people around us will respond to
our pain once it reaches their ears. We need
to remember to scream a little louder – and
hate ourselves a little less.
We've just launched an app to help you track down people with whome you can have
deeper more meaningful connections follow the link on your screen now to download it.